avant de se pencher sur la
présidentielle en france avec nos
invités on s'intéresse à la sphère
benalla devant la justice depuis ce
matin d'anciens collaborateurs
d'emmanuel macro est jugé pour plusieurs
va faire un procès étalés sur trois
semaines que celui pour nous notre
reporter monaco dès lors bonsoir von arx
alexandre bédat là qui comparaît donc
notamment pour avoir brutalisé un couple
lors des manifestations du 1er mai 2018
mais pas seulement
oui alors beaucoup de sujets ont été
abordés vous l'imaginez stéphanie lors
de cette première grande audience pour
alexandre benalla est la présidente du
tribunal correctionnel isabelle
prévost-desprez a commencé d'abord par
la lecture du rapport ainsi que tous les
sujets qui seront abordés tout au long
de ce procès alexandre dellal a ensuite
été convié à la barre la présidente a
épluché chaque ligne de son cv de son
parcours professionnel est la voix posée
plutôt bavard alexandre ben alla a
décrit sa fiche de poste alors qu'il
était à l'elysée il raconte notamment
avoir voulu rejoindre la république en
marche en septembre 2016 plutôt pour l'
aventure humaine que pour le côté
financier il dit je cite mon poste c'est
est de régler les problèmes mais ça
s'appelle directeur de la sécurité et de
la sûreté
et mona la présidente a abordé ensuite
la disparition du mystérieux coffre fort
au domicile d'alexandre benalla
exactement stéphanie il expliquait avoir
dissimulé car son adresse était devenu
public qu'il voulait éviter l'intrusion
de personnes mal intentionnées à son
domicile selon lui il n'avait jamais été
question de dissimuler la vérité son
avocate est ensuite intervenue pour
expliquer que la sphère du fameux coffre
fort et est toujours en cours ensuite
concernant le port d'armes hors cadre
professionnel c'est là que la situation
s'est légèrement tendu lors de cette
audience alexandre benalla expliqué
qu'il se sentait exposés au danger dans
sa vie personnelle et qu'il devait se
protéger en portant une arme il s'est
donc comparé aux policiers de
magnanville qui ont été tués et c'est là
que les explications n'ont pas convaincu
est la présidente qui l'a arrêté tout de
suite et qui lui a dit je cite là c'est
un petit peu limite monsieur ben alla et
mona la présidente est ensuite revenu
sur le fameux selphy de 2017 ou
alexandre bédat la tient une arme
moi je vous le disais stéphanie de
différents sujets ont été abordés
aujourd'hui c'était un petit peu le
moment cocasse de ce procès puisque le
cmfi a été projeté en salle d'audience
où les yeux à des journalistes de tes
parties civiles de la défense ce dernier
assure que cette arme est un glock
factice et que la photo est certes
idiote et inappropriée et des
déclarations qui n'ont vraisemblablement
pas convaincu est la présidente cette
audience elle s'est terminée aux
alentours de 19h30 elle reprendra dès
demain vous l'avez compris ce procès et
bien ils risquent d'être haut en
couleurs alexandre benalla va
comparaître jusqu'au 1er octobre soit
sept mois avant le premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle on suivra avec
vous merci mort en direct donc du
tribunal correctionnel de paris